parleremo di brutto
di bello di spazio pubblico attraverso
attraverso due progetti che vi illustro
stasera che ho curato condotto e che
considero soprattutto dalle operazioni
di rivoluzione dello sguardo delle
operazioni semiotiche e partendo da
molto lontano fino ad arrivare a
territori molto vicini a noi molto
vicini a potenza partiamo da baghdad
io sono stato ma nel 2009 iniziato una
ricerca
una ricerca sulle forme della
ricostruzione post bellica in tutti quei
territori in tutte quelle regioni
interessate da un conflitto
un conflitto militare a seguito
dell'attentato alle torri gemelle
quindi afghanistan il rock alcune fasce
del pakistan estendendo poi la ricerca
territori diciamo tangenti come
territori palestinesi alcuni confini
come metodo l'iraq e l'iran
e poi ancora in giordania
uso la fotografia il video come
strumenti privilegiati principali del
mio lavoro
questo è un workshop condotto insieme
agli studenti della facoltà di belle
arti dell'università di baghdad chiamato
mapping identity l'obiettivo di questo
workshop era quello di ridefinire
ridisegnare ricostruire una mappa della
città di baghdad non esistono mappe
della città di baghdad non c'è un
catasto l'unica mappa l'ultima mappa
risale al 2003 ed è una mappa realizzata
dalle forze americane dopo l'invasione
soprattutto per motivi di ordine
militare quindi non è una mappa che
permette effettivamente la comprensione
della morfologia del territorio
un chiaro orientamento a questo si
aggiunge il fatto che baghdad è una
città completamente nascosta blindata da
muri anche esplosioni che non permettono
assolutamente l'orientamento all'interno
del territorio urbano
in che cosa consisteva questo workshop
questo workshop consisteva in questo
abbiamo suddiviso la città di baghdad in
quadranti ogni quadrante si riferiva a
una porzione del territorio in cui uno
degli studenti abitava io ho chiesto a
loro di disegnare e raccontarmi come si
muovevano in questo in questa porzione
del territorio e quali erano i percorsi
che quotidianamente loro affrontavano e
di usare due colori 1 il nero in rosso e
il nero si riferisce agli anni
precedenti all'invasione
della coalizione condotta dagli
americani guidata dagli americani e il
rosso al periodo precedente quindi
indicando anche le trasformazioni
io ero dall'altra parte del del foglio e
riprendevo riprendevo per registrare
registrare anche i loro racconti ragazzi
mentre disegnavano raccontavano
raccontavano le trasformazioni di questi
luoghi è loro il loro quotidiano
questa è una mappa della disposizione
degli studenti non siamo naturalmente
riusciti a a
a mappare completamente tutto il
territorio è una collezione di otto
video che vengono montati ricostruiscono
brani della città i video erano 24 in
realtà insieme ai disegni 24 disegni di
cui ne sono rimasti solo 8 questi sono
alcuni esempi delle mappe risultanti
dietro questi blast bolsi si svolge la
vita la vita quotidiana e questi blast
all cambiano continuamente posizione a
seconda degli attacchi terroristici che
avvengono in città
check point plus quindi in qualche modo
frammentano il territorio urbano
trasformano la conoscenza l'identità di
un territorio in qualcosa di
estremamente frammentato e coatto di
esclusivo questa è una mappa molto
importante e disegnata da lì l'ultima
mappa ali non ha voluto disegnare ha
deciso di fare una cosa diversa cioè di
esportare un pezzo della mappa che noi
usavamo per potersi orientare per
definire i quadranti di esportarlo
perché lui in questo aperto in questo
pezzo di città non è mai entrato non lo
conosce questo pezzo di città si
riferisce alla green zone la parte
centrale di baghdad della parte
monumentale quella che ne definisce la
storia più eccezionale quella in cui
vengono racchiusi praticamente tutti i
segni e significati comuni quindi che
fanno la memoria reale di un luogo dove
ad esempio c'è il monumento al milite
ignoto disegnato da un architetto
italiano marcello d'olivo chiamato da
saddam a disegnare tutta una grande è
tutta una grande porzione dell'area
monumentale di baghdad oppure il
monumento di anzo vittori alla fine
della guerra tra l'iraq e l'iran perché
vi faccio vedere questo progetto perché
io in qualche modo penso non mi
interessa tanto la fotografia nel suo
essere documentazione mi interessa
piuttosto indagare le possibilità ei
limiti che vanno oltre la documentazione
la fotografia come documentazione quindi
mi interessa la fotografia come
strumento di istigazione all'azione
quello che penso quello che pensa e
quello che credo quello come affronto la
mia professione la fronte in termini di
responsabilità civile e politica
io penso che ognuno di noi nelle varie
discipline
nella sua attività quotidiana e in
qualche modo un avamposto contro lo
smemoramento cioè in qualche modo è un
anticorpo alla un processo che è in
corso e in atto che di eliminazione
completa di cancellazione di porzioni di
territorio
quando parlo di territorio non ne parlo
solamente in termini fisici io intendo
paesaggio in termini nella sua
dimensione materiale immateriale quindi
parlo di un paesaggio culturale
identitario questo processo in corso di
fronte di frammentazione di
frantumazione di demolizione di intere
parti di territorio non è tanto dovuta
al trauma al conflitto
quanto al tempo che segue questi
accadimenti che vuol dire immedesimarsi
nel trauma accettare il trauma
cosa intendo per accettazione del trauma
intendo accettare il fatto che il trauma
definisca i limiti della nostra
conoscenza cioè che definisca i limiti
della nostra sicurezza del paesaggio in
cui noi ci sentiamo sicuri in cui ci
conosciamo quindi noi smettiamo un certo
punto le nostre responsabilità civili e
politiche quotidiane smettiamo di essere
avamposti di conoscenza in questo senso
questo lavoro e in generale la pratica
che io adotto la considero che cerco
spero che venga considerata come uno
strumento per costruire dei ponti di
conoscenze avvicinare luoghi lontani
questo è quello che faccio sia
all'estero che in italia è l'ultimo
progetto uno degli ultimi progetti a cui
ho dedicato tre anni di ricerca si
chiama the third island la terza isola
si riferisce la calabria nasce da una
mostra alla biennale di venezia a cui
ero stato invitato cui ho presentato
come tema appunto quello delle grandi
opere con
in particolare interesse concentrando la
mia attenzione proprio sul caso sul caso
della calabria per che ricorrevano degli
anniversari 1964 l'inizio dei lavori per
la salerno reggio calabria e il 1994
l'apertura del porto di gioia tauro
entrambi questi due progetti si
inserivano all'interno di un piano molto
più ampio che era quello del pacchetto
colombo che prevedeva la costruzione del
quinto centro siderurgico europeo in un
periodo di piena cindy piena crisi della
siderurgia e un progetto che poi non è
non è stato mai attivato realmente non è
stato mai finalizzato queste sono alcune
immagini di gioia tauro dell'area
intorno al porto questa è l'opera che
abbiamo esposto alla biennale di venezia
in che cosa consiste quest'opera
quest'opera in realtà è un libro è un
libro di mario la cava un un autore al
cui io sono particolarmente affezionato
un autore calabrese nato a bovalino e ha
sempre vissuto a bovalino e questo è un
libro che si chiama caratteri e
raccogliere 359 caratteri di vita di
vita quotidiana di atteggiamenti di
accadimenti ed è uno dei più importanti
libri a mio avviso di fotografia
documentaria io sapevo che non avrei
potuto non
non era nelle mie possibilità quello di
restituire un ritratto aderente al al
territorio calabrese così complesso e
caleidoscopico come la realtà merita di
essere descritta e raccontata per cui ho
deciso di fare questo di prendere in
prestito il libro di mario la cava è per
me uno degli autori che effettivamente
nell'arco di quarant'anni di attività è
stato quello che ha deciso di dedicare
il suo la sua professione our a al al
racconto il più complesso possibile di
quello che era il suo territorio
considerando il suo territorio come
emblematico di sistemi e di mondi
globali e di visioni globali per cui
semplicemente o ristampato il libro e ho
aggiunto alcune immagini in alcuni casi
sostituendoli a delle pagine che
effettivamente raccontavano in quel
territorio
a questo progetto è seguita una rassegna
che è durata
un anno sul tema delle grandi opere di
approfondimento che si è conclusa con
una campagna fotografica massiva in cui
ho coinvolto undici fotografi italiani
il cui obiettivo era quello di indagare
queste grandi opere e soprattutto quello
di indagare il paesaggio culturale
fisico e culturale
intorno a queste grandi opere la salerno
reggio calabria e il porto di gioia
tauro per la salerno reggio calabria
soprattutto la parte che interessava
attraversava il territorio calabro
cercando di usarle e di considerarle
come un vettore per il riesame per la
una rivoluzione del nostro sguardo
rispetto al territorio calabrese cioè
un'autostrada e simbolo di un movimento
verso di un attraversamento in realtà
questo progetto si e mai si è
trasformato in un invito a tornare a
conoscere questo territorio che ai
margini della nostra conoscenza ai
margini della nostra identità nazionale
e continentale è un territorio in cui
noi abbiamo sempre abbiamo sempre
dedicato abbiamo in cui abbiamo sempre
emarginato e amando abbandonato il
peggio di noi in qualche modo in un
meccanismo di catartico di emancipazione
questi sono alcuni degli autori che
abbiamo che abbiamo invitato italiani e
non a discutere con noi di questo
territorio e più in generale del tema
delle grandi opere e ho realizzato una
mostra alla
a milano la triennale di milano queste
sono alcune immagini del territorio
calabrese guardando la salerno reggio
calabria abbiamo capito tante cose
abbiamo capito che l'autostrada è stata
prima di tutto uno strumento di
rivoluzione importante del carattere
identitario di questa regione una
regione che prima della costruzione
della salerno reggio calabria ancora
manteneva immutata e una struttura che
era quella del periodo risalente alla
magna grecia quindi una calabria che era
soprattutto introversa i cui centri
abitati
erano soprattutto all'interno della
regione e quei porti costieri erano
soprattutto erano potevano essere
considerati quasi delle darsene in magna
grecia infatti questi porti erano dei
porti di approvvigionamento ma la vita
si svolgeva tutto all'interno quindi era
una regione che non aveva mai guardato
al mare la salerno reggio calabria
introdotto il mito della velocità e lo
sguardo verso il mare producendo poi uno
spostamento anche delle attività
commerciali delle
di tutto il comparto residenziale verso
le coste trasformando completamente
l'aspetto di una regione una regione che
comunque non conosciamo e che ancora
detiene ed è caratterizzata da un
paesaggio giurassico un paesaggio
eccezionale abbiamo imparato a conoscere
anche alcuni record che non ci sono mai
stati raccontati il fatto che ad esempio
la salerno reggio calabria per 30 anni è
stato il luogo della di formazione della
più alta ingegneria mondiale c'è stato
il banco di prova il luogo di studio di
formazione per importi per i principali
dipartimenti di ingegneria civile
strutturale dell'intera europa
queste sono alcune immagini della prima
salerno reggio calabria ne sono state
costruite tre di salerno reggio calabria
in un territorio tra i più aspri
queste sono è la vecchia salerno reggio
calabria la prima salerno reggio
calabria in fase di naturalizzazione
queste sono le opere di demolizione su
questa è la vecchia salerno reggio
calabria questo è il viadotto italia
appena riaperto dove è stato posato
l'ultimo concedi trave e queste sono
alcune immagini ancora della
naturalizzazione di un paesaggio in
continua trasformazione in continua
rivoluzione questo è il libro che
raccoglie questa ricerca quello di cui
parlava
con cui mi hanno introdotto e raccoglie
il lavoro di tutti gli autori più
infografiche che raccontano il porto è
quella degli inserti e su questo mi
vorrei soffermare un attimo 38 secondi è
un dizionario analogico questo
dizionario analogico raccoglie una serie
di definizioni di ricercatori
internazionali a cui ho chiesto di
portare una nuova definizione del
concetto di grande opera e si chiama
analogico perché i dizionari analogici
funzionano per definizione cioè
attraverso le definizioni riusciamo a
rintracciare un termine e non viceversa
per cui alcuni di loro mi hanno parlato
di equatore politico altri mi hanno
parlato di conoscenza alcuni mi hanno
parlato di ibridazione digitale altri di
migrazione cioè definivano la grande
opera con questi termini attraverso
queste definizioni questi fenomeni
perché vi faccio vedere questo perché io
credo nel brutto
credo nel brutto come un processo un
processo un processo che può essere
identificato attraverso un sistema molto
chiaro di forze politiche ed economiche
che intervengono su un sistema di
relazioni di relazioni sociali di
reazioni identitari che definiscono un
ruolo specifico trasformandolo da
pubblico ha privato i caratteri che
definiscono uno spazio pubblico sono due
sono l'imprevedibilità e la trasparenza
sono due caratteri complementari
imprescindibili senza uno di questi lo
spazio uno spazio un paesaggio non può
essere definito spazio pubblico o
addirittura bene comune quando parlo di
imprevedibilità e intendo la possibilità
che si manifestino delle trasformazioni
profonde nel carattere nel carattere
fisico e culturale nella nella portata
simbolica nel memoriale nella dimensione
nella condizione identitaria di un luogo
lo spazio pubblico è sempre e sempre
un'infrastruttura di rivoluzione una
rivoluzione trasparente nel momento in
cui nasce da un rapporto profondo e
chiaro con il luogo in cui si manifesta
e cresce
come responsabilità condivise e diventa
un dispositivo di emancipazione in
questo senso la rivoluzione è sempre
innovazione questo vuol dire che lo
spazio pubblico detona innovazione
facendo dell'imprevedibilità e carattere
genetliaco delle sue pratiche il
territorio ne diviene immagine innovata
appunto immagine esemplare
quindi noi praticamente cambiamo la
rivoluzione è sempre un cambiamento dei
significati che compongono le città cioè
noi dotiamo dei luoghi dei simboli che
compongono lecite abbiamo alle relazioni
nuovo nuovo ruolo portandolo portandoli
ad emanciparsi in maniera improvvisa e
totalmente inaspettata in questo senso
la rivoluzione è sempre una rivoluzione
dello sguardo cioè noi cambiamo lo
sguardo per cambiare la convinzione
comune e triviale che abbiamo dei
significati che compongono il territorio
in questo senso io vorrei dire che la
rigenerazione la trasformazione è sempre
un'operazione semiotica e principalmente
di sguardo
non si può pensare lo spazio pubblico
non si può pensare il bello e non lo si
può rigenerare lo possiamo trasformare
nel momento in cui noi lo possiamo
generale nel momento in cui noi stessi
siamo portatori di innovazione siamo
delle rivoluzioni delle infrastrutture
di rivoluzione
il bello è sempre spazio pubblico grazie